Hey,
wise crack jared,
as always,
so ubisoft recently reached out to us
about doing something for the newly
remastered version of assassin's creed
rogue for ps four and xbox one.
Luckily for them,
we've gotten a lot of assassin's creed
requests over the years and luckily for
us,
rogue has a unique perspective on the
eternal struggle between the assassins
and the templars and how it relates to
the complicated nature of freedom
throughout the series.
The value of freedom is placed above all
else.
How are we in shall freedom public human
race,
the assassins were told are fighting the
good fight against those devious 10
players who are trying to rule the world
with an iron fist.
While freedom is nearly universally
celebrated in society and Media Qb
legally safe.
William Wallace knockoff.
Yeah.
Through which protagonists Shay Cormac,
assassin's creed rogue asked an
interesting and unique question.
When does freedom go too far?
Welcome,
Liz.
Wise,
crack condition on assassin's creed,
rogue remastered,
and as always,
minor spoilers ahead.
First,
a quick recap rope takes place around
the numerically challenged seven years
war and somewhere between black flag and
assassin's creed.
Three,
we follow fledgling assassin.
Shay Cormac,
a troublemaker who begins to question
the assassin brotherhoods,
methods,
guards watching
to his dad looked disappointed,
sick of the way that looks it would have
been dead in a month.
Anyway,
he continues to struggle with defending
his creed until halfway through the
game.
He's given an assignment to find a piece
of ed or an ancient objects had to
bestow God like power and wisdom because
pieces of Eden,
a powerful relics.
When Shay tries to retrieve it,
he triggers the infamous Lisbon
earthquake of 1755 that killed
thousands.
Despite what's happened in Haiti,
happened in Portugal or greater
earthquake.
Thousands,
he confronts the assassins who deny
culpability for the earthquake,
even though they were aware of the same
thing,
had caused the devastating earthquake in
Puerto Prince five years earlier.
She argues that over here to this side,
what city funds decks,
but the assassin say we have the
responsibility,
so shay flees the Brotherhood.
After being injured in his escape,
he's nurse back to health by an elderly
couple who turned out to be templars.
Shay is then recruited by the temp lars
and send to kill his former assassin.
Brethren,
in most assassin's creed games were told
the templars are evil because they
oppose freedom and the assassins are
good because they fight for freedom,
which is best embodied in their mantra,
but assassin's creed rogue by showing
the inner workings of both sides
explores the paradoxical nature of
freedom and the shortcomings of the
assassins belief system.
Sure,
the assassin seen noble.
I mean after all,
you don their mantle as you fight
against the corruption of the church and
histories other bad guys,
but just how benign is the saying when
you consider the events of rogue,
the assassins disposition toward
absolute freedom starts looking a bit
questionable.
We can best understand why through the
concept of positive freedom,
positive freedom is the freedom to do
something and to self determine what
that something is.
It's the freedom to choose to blast
weird German techno whenever you want.
That's different than negative freedom.
The freedom from certain external forces
like the freedom from your roommate,
Brad telling you to stop blasting German
techno at 2:00
AM or brad common during your stereo.
The problem with unlimited freedom is
that it often comes in conflict with the
rights and freedoms of others.
While you may be the master of your own
fate,
what if your actions limit the freedom
of others?
What if Brad can't be the master of his
own destiny because he hasn't gotten any
sleep after the unceasing onslaught of
Autobahn every night until 2:00
AM,
and if you reject any limitations on
freedom from outside interferences or
negative freedom,
who's going to step in to help Brad get
some sleep?
If everything is permitted,
then people might not agree with when
and how I want to listen to music.
The temple ours address this problem of
freedom.
By negating it all together,
they in essence don't believe in the
value of positive freedom.
That people can make their own decisions
or negative freedom,
that they should be free from despotic
control.
Their philosophy is essentially that the
freedom of one person will always end up
rubbing against someone else's,
and so such freedom must be restricted.
Philosopher Isaiah Berlin highlights one
way in which these self determination of
positive freedom can have horrific
results.
Freedom for Berlin can often be defined
collectively with others groups,
tribes,
or even nations can set out to define
their own destiny,
and that's where things get a little
tricky.
Since in the name of collective freedom,
many have decided to repress minority
groups.
The German people collectively yearned
for the freedom to determine their
national destiny,
but well,
we all know how that turned out for
certain groups in Europe.
Now obviously the assassins and the
Nazis are about as similar as Mozart and
Fred Durst,
but the assassins are willing to
sacrifice the freedom of some for the
sake of freedom for everybody.
If we're all free to do whatever the
hell we want and the assassins don't
mind.
Earthquakes killing thousands then is
absolute freedom.
Really the ultimate good.
The templar seemed to understand this
problem with positive freedom with
people being their own masters,
so they try to actively suppress it.
In the name of a better world,
what marvelous destruction captain,
I saw the smoke all the way from the
Morrigan that should discourage those
Miss Greens.
New Yolk is safe for now and as rogue
shows,
they're not as misguided as one may
think.
Paradoxically,
certain rights and freedoms can be
enhanced with a heavy hand from say the
government or the templars.
So for instance,
by limiting someone's freedom to enslave
another person,
logging in states a better version of
freedom,
not predicated on owning other humans.
We see this conundrum in other
assassin's creed games such as black
flag where the British templarios
cracked down the pirates.
You play as in the name of safer sees
and liberty for woodby pirate victims.
The templars believe they know best and
that order can be achieved through
guidance and rule.
But this isn't exactly a perfect
ideology either.
The total control of individuals for the
sake of greater good can lead to your
typical big brother Dystopian nightmare.
So while causing earthquakes,
stealing fortunes and slitting throats
is okay.
If nothing is the polar opposite is that
we should all be thanking our masters
for living under a Jack boot,
but hey police,
they're open about it.
What makes rogue unique is that shade
distances himself from the dogmatic
belief structures that characterize the
protagonists of previous games and
embraces a rationally informed moral
choice,
but the shea make the right choice.
Well to figure that out.
We'll need help from one of the big dogs
of the European Enlightenment Manual
Count during the enlightenment,
formulated a way to ground morality in
reason instead of religion or custom
known as the categorical imperative.
So let's see how Shay's decision stacks
up.
The first formulation act only according
to that maxim whereby you can will that
it should become a universal law sort of
boils down to do unto others.
So if you want to know if killing people
and then searching their bodies for loot
is moral,
you should consider what will happen if
everyone follows this rule.
The second is to act in such a way that
you treat humanity never merely as a
means to an end,
but always at the same time.
As an end.
This essentially means that life is the
highest value in and of itself,
so never harm others or exploit them as
a means of achieving some bigger goal.
The final rule says that the will of
every rational beings should be thought
of as a universally legislating will.
This ties the first two together and
suggest that there is a universal reason
or logic that we can all access through
our own rationality.
It also offers a framework that includes
a sense of freedom since every person is
capable of participating in this kind of
moral reasoning where without the
dangers of the templars of the
assassins,
where people become freedom list ponds
to their grander plans.
Even if paradoxically freedom is part of
that grander plan.
According to current,
no action or morals are ethical if they
contradict these three rules.
So let's see how shay scores against the
assassins shade defects because he
believed that by causing an earthquake
and justifying it as part of their
responsibility,
the assassins have done a grave
injustice.
This act violates the first formulation
because it implies killing thousands for
your own end,
which could never be a universal ethical
act.
One point for Shay,
zero for the assassin's the assassin's
are also saying that those lives are
acceptable sacrifices for their greater
goal,
a violation of the second principle,
because using people as a means to an
end is a big no,
no.
Another point for Shay,
and finally through their belief in
total freedom,
the assessments are trampling on
people's legislative will by ignoring
their own agency and literally
destroying their homes and autonomous
lives which contradicts const.
Third formulation.
Shay wants no part of it,
so three points for Shay,
zero for the assassins.
So what can we learn from shades
decision that fighting for freedom is
not so simple by pursuing their own
freedom,
the assassins have destroyed the
freedoms of others,
but by rejecting the indoctrinated
philosophy of nothingness,
Jay could be among the few ethical
heroes of the assassins creed franchise.
Unfortunately for Shay,
the temple,
ours aren't exactly model citizens
either in the name of regulating freedom
for the greater good,
the templars do plenty of deplorable
things.
We see them helping local people in
various places.
Now,
let us use some of that money for the
good of the city and stopping the
assassins from committing what amounts
to a war crime.
There is an abandoned factory nearby,
how dangerous poison,
but we also see them lie,
maim and kill in the name of their own
creed.
In the end,
the same sense of moral dubiousness
follows the templars as much as the
assassins.
When I am issued new recruits burdened
with regrets,
I tell them the surest way to lose them.
He's with gunpowder with them both
contradicting constant parative by using
people as a means to their own ends and
killing those who stand in their way.
Assassin's creed rogues more nuanced
exploration of freedom,
good and evil is a welcome addition to
the series Shay's decision to betray the
assassins,
brings the philosophies of both factions
under scrutiny and makes the player view
each in an entirely new life.
Was this moral ambivalence about freedom
always there.
Have we been playing as the bad guys?
All along,
here's to hoping.
This complex question gets explored in
future installments,
but until then,
be sure to check out the remastered
version of assassin's creed rogue out
now on xbox one and ps four.
Be sure to check out the link in the
description to learn more about the game
and you might be interested in checking
out this really awesome trailer if the
game.
Thanks again to Ubisoft for giving us
this opportunity and as always,
thanks for watching guys.
Piece.